gentlemen
Is the final Rose tonight look the only choice? She's got she's not gonna move to a farmer those heels she's kissed him all
with her tongue
Rivertown she's a Walking Venereal disease
Chase
Seeing an overdrawn balance in your daily checking yeah, my mortgage payment tripled
I've disclosed a possibility of a rate hike during your refi. Do you remember that?
everyone on the ground now the three men walked off with
1.6 million dollars [I] choreographed it like a thong a conga line right into prison they didn't get cool
Semtex steel has frozen all pension payments
I'm thinking of robbing a bank. I'm thinking about buying a ferrari. [I] just not have to buy the knicks could we pray about huh?
Williamsburg Savings will manage the liquidation of the fund, these banks
Practically destroyed this country and nothing ever happened [to] them. I want to rob the bank
Let's go get our money back. Yeah
We pictograph [what's] on the pension right? That's all I want. what if we get more. We give it to charity
It's time for a practice run. We'll be right back. I don't want to stay in the car. It's hot in here
Hello, Hal gotta get some chicken thighs first are better than thighs don't you think?
Never has anybody walked off with a whole pork [line] jump into the basket. who the hell  you think I am a E.T?
I don't know What's going on in the world anymore [look] what you did to Cindy? She's looking like a Colombian drug mule
We're gonna need professional help, you think!
you five-O
We're practically eight-O
from now on you can morning heat by texting. How do you work on all those buttons its a touch screen.
I'm groping it all over nothing is happening. It reminds me at a time. We went to the arena. We ate like Kings
working, we still are
ladies and gentlemen
halt,halt then what are you chasing me for don't make me taze you. this is not a admission of yelt i am just tired .